and uh i was pacing back and forth the
train station was like i'm done the way
i was just spoken to even though it
wasn't my fault
i can't keep taking this
like
i i i'm done i'm done i'm done and they
i think brave even just say that to your
agent who's like you know you they want
you to have confidence and have passion
for this i don't think they cared
because they weren't like super high up
they were mainly commercial agent and
they
really booked a lot of at like
commercials
so it wasn't like i was with
united or someone who you know
they were kind of like oh all right like
it wasn't like a big deal having a
breakdown yeah exactly well and they
knew i'd come back or something i don't
know maybe we all do it yeah yeah so
they were like well you know hold that
thought take the weekend i'm sorry that
you had a bad time in the meantime we
have just got an audition for you for a
pilot for rob thomas it's called izombie
and this happened at the same time at
the same train station acting yeah 100
and they said i zombie and i was like
sound [ __ ]
it sounds like something terrible what
does it mean yeah it's a [ __ ] app
what is this right and and they were
like it's a comic book it's a pilot for
the cw
i was like okay cool whatever and they
sent the sides and i looked at it
and i attacked it in a way i wouldn't
have attacked it that weekend
i attacked it in a point to prove way
that i was
capable i've had this but it's it's a
rare thing when you just
you're sort of like [ __ ] it
rarely do we ever say [ __ ] it we care
too much we need it we've got to stay
the stakes are high we need to make
money we need to impress people and
prove ourselves and
and you were at a position where you
were like
i'm gonna [ __ ] quit anyway and then i
got this you know what [ __ ] it who gives
a [ __ ]
you had this for certain mentality or
your energy was just
what do i have to lose exactly there was
no stakes anymore and this was a really
i've said this before in
something but
it's a really good note for other actors
about their auditions if they're
watching
i couldn't wait to perform it and i
hadn't felt like that in a long time wow
like show and tell usually you're afraid
of it yeah and i was like i can't wait
to [ __ ] monday
what time two o'clock can't wait
because i knew it was good and i knew i
put work into it
and i get to the audition i remember the
character brief
it said highly caffeinated that was the
character brief this character is scotty
he's a highly caffeinated
uh medical examiner scotty scotty from
star trek ah he's that he's that kind of
like he's the brains and he's a little
bit bigger than life and all of this
stuff
so i get it i get it ready i get up on
its feet i remember like
showing it to my family and stuff like
that and they they liked it i've never
done that on the train ride to like
central london
i started to doubt myself and i was like
auditions too big
you're too big
you're too caffeinated
dial it back and by the time i've walked
to the front door of the audition uh the
carson director's place
i've talked myself out of doing what you
wanted to do yeah as big and fast as i
could do it so i started to dial it back
and this is the the best thing that's
ever happened to me my entire [ __ ]
life where my career is concerned
the room i sat in
i chose a seat randomly i sat here and
the carson director's assistant's
computer was there
okay and everyone was in the room and
we're all sitting there and it was every
brown dude from england
we all look the same and we're all
sitting there and i could see on her
screen she was cutting together other
tapes and i could see multiple tapes
and they were playing people that she
liked
or she was just she was just
the auditions
and none of them even though i couldn't
hear audio none of them were moving and
i was like oh [ __ ] none of them are
highly caffeinated no one's got any big
energy everyone's
brought it down you could see
from their energy during their tape
they're like this
and they're just and you're like
everybody's doing that everyone's doing
it so i went [ __ ] that go back do do
what you could do do it fast it doesn't
matter if you trip up do it
so being able to see a computer i was
like all right i'm gonna do what so wait
wait so this computer saved you yeah
yeah because i wouldn't have done it
that way i would have i talked myself
out of it i was like it's too big
you're going too fast it's not that it's
not right and i could see the screen and
then like i said i could see everyone
else's energy without even hearing the
dialogue was wrong i got in the room
name royal coley cool age did a slate
sit down
bang i hit it the minute it starts
and i and i didn't trip and i got
through the two pages of this this
[ __ ] dialogue i remember the cast
note to sat back
and she went
have you auditioned for me before and i
was like i don't know maybe she's like
how long have you been doing this for
i was like eight years and she was like
where have you been
i remember her saying that and then i
felt this like adrenaline rush and i was
like oh [ __ ] she likes me she likes me
because do you have a green card oh like
are you passport valid and everything
so your heart starts pounding and i was
like uh
yeah i do she was like wow okay cool uh
well thank you so much we'll speak to
you later